。
同学们好啊，咱们上课。
嗯，这次挺久没上课了。
挺不好意思的。
再加上前段时间呢，咱们上过线下课，对吧？
嗯，有些同学也看到了，所以会产生些疑问，说老师是不是转战线下了，线上课不给更了。
没有这个意思啊。
这个前段时间。
有点生病，身体不太好啊，所以导致更新。
暂停了一下。
也有同学问，他们为什么不把线下课直接上传呢？
这个有啥好藏着掖着呢？
完全没有藏在这掖着的意思啊，线下课声音没怎么录好，本来也是打算上传的啊。
嗯，不过同学们不用担心啊，因为这个知识啊就是这些。
呃，咱们线下也好，线上也好，都会讲到的。
内容都是一样的啊。
今天呢就给大家讲一讲线下课里面讲过的一些内容，给大家补一补。
当然，线下课不可能跟线上课完全一样啊。
知识可以一样。
但是扯淡不一样。
为啥呢？因为有些蛋吧只能在线下扯，你在线上扯吧。
容易招骂对吧？比如说我说我刚才我刚才说我。
生病了。
身体不太好。
我生着这个病。
就政治不正确。我如果在我在线下，我就大大方方的说，我是因为什么，然后回去之后呢，产生了什么样的反应，然后啊剧烈，对吧？卧床不起。
但是在线上就不能这么说，因为你线上一旦说这种话，马上就会有人骂你说你什么意思？
你是要诋毁什吗？
你是不是要破坏我们这个大好形势，对吧？
你你要不你去国外吧，是吧？
滚回你的国家去是吧？全是这种话。
真的一点不夸张啊。
这个咱们上的这个课啊。
咱们上的这个课是个垂直领域的课。
按理说呢都是爱学习的同学，但是这个你再垂直你一个东西放在网上之后啊，还是有很多无关的群众会看到。
所以呢。
我基本上每个礼拜被骂个三四次吧。
不是很多，但是呢也有就经常骂骂你哎呀，你算的什么东西，舔着脸来讲，对吧？或者你在课程里面举过例子。比如说你举某个片子的例子，或者某个人的例子，他们也会骂你说你哎呀，你不懂就不要说，你懂个屁，对吧？
或者是。
没有什么原因，比如说你穿了衣服。
品牌不对，也会有人骂，对吧？说啊，这个品牌用什么什么棉花，对吧？
问题我录课的时候，我也不知道他会那样呀，对吧？
还有什么对吧呃你们这些影视圈的人还出来叨叨什么，拍的戏那么烂，还不快去给郑州捐款吧？
都会有这样那样的一些。
声音啊。
这个很正常啊。
呃，首先。
我一般看到这种事儿吧，我还是比较平和的啊，大家不用替我担心。有同学以为说老师，你是不是老师有人喷你，你不愿讲了呢？
呃，完全没有啊，大家不用担心，我对这个事情是怎么看的呢啊？就是关于网上有很多人。
嗯，喷攒或者是喷别人。
呃。
我其实挺开心的这个事儿。
两个原因。一。
每逢喷我们的人比较多的时候啊。
就证明咱们的课传播的比较好的时候。
因为咱们的课如果不传播的时候，内卷，那就全部是咱们自己的学生都很爱学习，他不可能喷，对吧？凡是有人骂呢，一般是这个课呢又传播到新的平台了，又有新的一帮人看到了，那自然爱学习的就学了，不爱学的呢，骂几句喷几句很正常，对吧？
这是我开心的第一个原因。
第二个原因呢就是。
为什么会有人喷你呢？
是因为话语权的下放也不叫下放吧，我们叫它话语权的普及和公平，就是人人都有发表意见的权利。
我认为这是个好事情，虽然有人会骂。
但我认为它是个好事情，为啥呢？因为这是我们年轻人的机会。
我自己就是通过这种机会入行上位的对吧？当年有互联网的时候。
实现了话语权的一次下放。我趁着那个机会，对吧？主流电视台你进不去啊。主流电视台我说过，当时能买得起首轮剧的就9家。
你进不去。
对吧你趁着这个下放的机会，哎，你进到这个行业了。
咱们不能说咱们趁这个机会上来了，然后就开始把门关掉，下面的人别上来了，对吧？谁也不许骂我了。
那你就太缺德了，对不对？你上传了，你你就知道什么上房蹬梯子，对不对？那不行呀，咱是通过这种机会上来的。
那么现在新的交互形式，新的媒体形式不断的把。
话语权把公平公正的交流方式下放给。
更多的人。
这是好事儿。
对于年轻人来说，只是机会，这是好事情。所以里面有个别的骂声呢。
也挺好的，也正常。我们应该用平和的心态去对待。
赶紧上课。
赶紧上课，不扯淡，好吧，因为为啥呢？
这个这个这个学习时间啊是很宝贵的。虽然是网课，没有人掐点儿，但是咱们呢也尽量。
呃，讲干货，从后面的课程开始啊，我们就不扯淡了。
当然有人喜欢听扯淡，有同学喜欢听扯淡。那我们可以单独。比如说直播的时候，咱们就纯扯淡扯个够。好吧，上课的时候呢，我们就讲知识吧，以后还是做到干湿分离，对吧？上课就讲干货，我们干湿分离，好吧，这节课讲什么干货呢？这节课的干货呢有点干。
确实有点干，就是。
我想给大家讲一讲原理性的东西，本源性的东西，为啥呢？是因为我这个在跟同学接触的过程中啊。
我发现一个问题啊。
就是。
我们讲太多的技术，讲太多的方法以后，很多同学在创作中啊。
呃，忘记了讲故事的本源，忘记了本心了，忘记创作。
本身最初的那个出发点了，忘记初心了，这么说吧，就是他过度的讲究方法。
当然我还发现另外一个问题，就是通过上线下课呀，或者是通过跟很多同学接触呀。
很多同学拿这个这个这个这个。
他写了东西给我看。
我这个人因为讲课讲了也一年多了，跟同学们我也不拿大家当外人了。所以我说的话就比较实在。我就就一看，哎呀，我说哎呀这位保友。
你这个东西你这个东西不行啊，这作为保友，这这这不行啊，这这什么玩意儿？
结果啊我就发现那个同学从此以后再也没有出现过。
就就我我也不知道他可能也退群了吧，就是自从班级群里直接就退掉了。
这个要不得啊，就是咱们不能这个。
同学们不能这个太脆弱啊，虽然你感觉你听了一年的课会了一些方法了，但是。
这个这个不代表你现在能打。
这个一定要保持心态啊，因为写东西啊。
呃。
没有那么难，但也没有那么简单，你得多练。
大部分同学拿给我的东西啊，是他的第一个作品。
第一个作品呢一般倾注的心血是确实是比较多。他自己呢有一个很美好的遐想，对这个东西。所以我一旦说不好呢。
他的这个这个心情就确实受到了一定的打击，但是也有那种心态好的，脸皮比较厚的同学，就老师，你就给我找个亮点呗。
我说这硬找吗？他说你找个亮点给我点信心啊，我说可能就是。
但是就是真没有啊，对吧？同学们一定保持好的心态啊，写东西这个东西这玩意儿吧，你就得练，没有说一蹴而就的，说第一个就就一定。
你写的第一个就很好，这个几率非常之小非常之小。你人生写的第一个剧本就能让我夸，让我觉得好。这个那我就是在骗你的对吧？这个很难的。
就像我上礼拜去去去去。
去去学学打拳。
我去健身房学了一节。
大拳。
道理也是这样，跟咱们学编剧差不多，就是什么呢？
就。
咱们那些同学拿句来给我看的那些同学啊，就是自以为自己很能打。
他可能也在学校也打过仗，可能也是个小霸凌，对吧？挺牛逼的。
混小混混。
但问题是你在马路上再能打。
我相信你也打赢过，对吧？但是你在马路上再也能打。
你去前台上看看。
你去看看那个教练。
你去看看那些专业人士。
我跟你说，你你小时候再能打。
你跟那个人打他我他保证5秒之内就放倒你。
专业跟业余差距就是这么大。所以不要大家不要凭天赋，觉得自己挺能打的。
这个就上去要跟专业人士比划比划。
我很客观的告诉你。
还得练很正常啊，咱们赶紧上课。
这节课讲本源性的问题，啥本源性的问题呢？就是。
我们为什么要？
看电影。
看电视剧。
因为这个问题如果没搞清楚的话。
你在根儿上你就就偏了。
所以这节课啊按理说我是应该早点讲。
是吧就是这种课其实应该放在前面讲的。
今天咱就把它补上。
呃，希望能对同学们的创作有所帮助吧。
因为这个问题啊。
确实它是根儿上的问题。你如果根儿上。
瞄的不正，瞄的不准，那你一路跑偏，对吧？
我们来研究一下说。
人为什么要看电影？人为什么要看电视剧？
这个本源性的东西。
我们说啊影视作品。
首先它是个艺术，对吧？它是个艺术品。
那我们先从第一个。
第一个概念。
去研究。
第一个问题。
就是人为什么需要艺术呢？
艺术肯定是人类独有的对吧？动物是不需要的。就说我们人啊为什么需要艺术这个东西嘞？
我说艺术，你看有有这个这个这个绘画，对吧？这个这个早期的古代的这个绘画，然后咱们这还有诗歌是吧？还音乐。
哎，还有舞蹈嘞，对吧？还有舞蹈艺术。
然后还有这个这个这个再就还有咱们影视艺术，就是艺术这个东西，你说人为什么需要呢？
有同学会说，那可能就是闲的吧。
是吧闲的没事干就搞点艺术，吃饱了啊，饿着肚子的时候肯定不想搞嘛，吃饱了搞。
这么说不全面啊不准确啊。
我先给大家一个定义。
艺术是什么呢？
艺术是人类语言表达的补充。
就是艺术这个东西啊是补充我们语言表达的。
因为人啊是个社群洞。
是个社会性的东。
社会性的动物啊需要沟通，需要交流。
最基本的方式当然是语言。
对吧语言文字是我们的重大发明啊，语言啊语言是是重大的发明，而且语言是人类的本能。
人类的本能，你把一个小孩扔在哪儿，他就学会那里的语言了啊，不用小孩，大人其实扔的你把你扔在西班牙。我跟你说，西班牙语很快也就。
学会了。
就是。
人有个沟通的一个本能。
最基本的方法。
啊，就是语言表达。
艺术呢？
是语言表达的。
补充。
能好理解吗？
理解好理解，但是觉得有点。
不太信是吧？
我们这么想啊，你看。
我们先说刚才的艺术形式来。
你说画画。
美术这个东西啊。
我们说画画在古代是非常盛行的，现在比较少了。
现在纯画画的。
画家已经很少了啊，但古代很多。那你说古代为什么那么多。
这人画画。
是因为古代的人啊很多不识字儿。
他看不了字儿，他只能看画。
所以你看早期的画画的是什么？西方画的是教会画。
传教用的。
它是传播教义用的，它其实就是取代文字。如果人人都能读圣经，我们还画画干什么？
明白吧？所以它其实就是语言表达的一个补充。
本质啊我们说的是本质啊。
本质是这样的。
所以你看随着十字率的普及。
随着大家都认字了，随着语言表达方式的多样化，对吧？其他补充方式的多样化画画啊现在。
职业的画家越来越少了，我们只能这么说，对吧？当然有很我们的同学中有很多就是画画了。
他们在画什么？
他们在画漫画。
画动漫。
或者是搞动画。
对吧。
那是什么玩意儿？
那不就是在拥抱语言表达吗？对吧？你纯画画没人看。
你还是得画一个。
故事画一个情节，画一个语言表达。
对不对？拥抱与文字，拥抱文学才能活下去。
其他的东西也是这样呀，你说纯音乐来大家年轻人都觉得自己我喜欢音乐，我对音乐挺爱的，纯音乐你们谁听？
有几个人听纯音乐的。
对吧懂旋律吗？
懂乐器吗？大家不懂大家听的是什么啊？
听的是歌儿。
对不对？秋顿听的是歌，大家喜欢听的是歌，为什么喜欢听歌？
语言表达嘛。
对吧音乐这个艺术。
也参与到语言表达中来，才能获得我们大家的喜欢和认可。
而且他确实是语言表达的补充呀。
为啥呢？
你把你喜欢的歌，比如说什么薛之谦的歌或者是。
什么毛不易的歌。
你你把歌词拿出来。
虽然是哎有的歌词是表达失恋的情绪的，有的歌词是表达对一个异性的爱慕的情绪的。
你拿着读给一个异性听一听。
他绝对觉得你有病。
那些词儿你能说得出口的。
歌里面的词你能说得出口的。
不配上曲儿，干说的话简直就是有病。
明白这个道理吧？
但是我们需要表达那样的情绪。
我们就哎哼着表达，哎，你看唱的表达就没有那么尴尬了，对吧？
所以你看他就是语言表达的补充。
那些词儿呢我们。
干说有点牙碜。
配上曲说哎，这个行对吧？而且还自己自己挺陶醉，有时候给自己感动的就想哭，你看这就是。
歌。
也是。
语言表达的不充。
所以说啊举举两个例子啊，说的就是艺术这个东西啊。
它的本质其实就是。
语言表达的补充。我么大家这么去理解，我不喜欢讲概念，但是你们要理解好吧，你们要理解它的原理。
那。
我们说主流艺术还有一个概念啊，还有一个定义，主流艺术啊实际上是。
统治阶级传达价值观的工具。
这是主流艺术啊。
因为你如果不传达统治阶级的价值观的话，你这个艺术很难形成主流，很难形成大众传播。
比如说你看西方的。
我们说西方的文艺作品，西方的艺术往往传播。比如说。
这个这个。
宗教的一些。
理念对吧？传播他们这个这个信仰基督教的一些信仰的一些理念主题。你看美国的电影特别喜欢传播什么公平正义，传播什么个人英雄主义。
这就是他们的。
主流价值观，他们统治阶级的价值观。
对吧你看咱们东方，比如说咱们中国，咱们的统治阶级呢是人民，对吧？人民当家做主嘛。
我们的。
价值观是什么嘞？
对吧我们的价值观比如说是勤劳善良。
或者是这个这个这个中军爱国。
对吧或者是孝道，或者是善恶有报。你看我们的主流。
艺术作品需要传播这种价值观。
你如果不传播这种价值观也是不行的。
所以说这也是一个概念啊，就主流艺术它传播的是这个社会的主流价值观，也就是统治阶层的。
我们也要记住，不要。
老师。
在这方面搞颗粒雏行，那就没有意思了，那就没有意义了，对吧？那就不是艺术了。
那是你自己的事儿，好吧。
我们说我们既然搞清楚了这是艺术的定义啊呃它就是这个语言表达的补充。我们说。
那在这个现在的这个这个这个时代下。
这个艺术的。
他这个生存现状是什么呢？
现在这个社会啊。
我们说是一个。
交互性的社会刚才也说了啊，就是大家的话语权都很丰富，很很很公平啊，大家都在这个这个这个。
表达。
大家都在语言表达。
所以呢导导致了一个什么样的状态啊？
现在一个是一个什么样的状态呢？现在是一个。
疯狂的争夺。
疯狂的争夺每一个用户的。
时间的一个状态。
所有的艺术形式都在疯狂的争夺。
用户的。
时间。
比如说。
比如说最近两个月。
影视作品的流量非常差。
就是甭管你是什么影视作品，最近两个月全部铺街，全部赔钱。
为啥呢？
7月份。
是我们建党100周年。
8月份。
东京的奥运会。
就是这两件事情，把大家的目光，把大家的注意力，把大家的时间都给吸引走了。我们在听这两件事情对我们进行表达。
所以呢。
所有的影视作品，所有的文艺形式，所有的艺术。
都会受到冲击，这就是现在的现实状况，就是你一个艺术作品啊，你不光要跟其他艺术作品搏杀了。
你要跟所有的东西搏杀，是因为。
现在是一个信息交互的时代。所以你看啊为啥说短视频出来之后，影视作品反而呃影视作品不好干了，受冲击，长篇受冲击，按道理是两个门类啊？
你刷抖音，你爱刷刷呗，对吧？你刷短视频，你爱刷刷呗。
怎么会影响看电影呢？
是因为。
所有用户，所有个体的注意力。
所有。
所有个体的时间已经被抢光了。
导致。
现在的艺术作品。
生存现状其实不是很好，要跟很多东西搏杀。
要跟很多东西播啥。我其实课上讲过啊，我说你看一下你每天的时间分配，你基本上就知道中国谁有钱了。
你每天花两个小时在抖音上，我跟你说，张一鸣现在很有钱，对吧？你每天花一个小时在淘宝上马云那是曾经也是中国首富呀，对吧？你每天还花一个半小时在微信上嘿马化腾也相当有钱，对吧？你每天呢花那个。
半个小时在滴滴打车上，你看滴滴那家伙也很有钱，对不对？你每天还要送叫快递，你花你花时间在哪儿，花精力在哪？
哪里就很富裕。
所以说人的时间啊已经被抢的差不多了，已经被抢的差不多了，你还要跟资本大鳄抢呢。
所以为什么现在鼓励赶紧生二胎，生三胎？就是人不够用了，对吧？不够巧了。所以说艺术品啊艺术作品啊，包括影视作品。
现在就是。
艺术作品的它的生命线就叫。
注意力和时间就叫。
用户的attention加time对吧？就是需要用户的时间和注意力。
但是现在呢。
分流这个时间的东西太多了。所以艺术总体来讲是在往下走的。
从目前来说啊，目前这个现阶段的情况来说是在往下走。
因为。
大家的时间太少了。
时间太少了。
过去没有。
你这么多资讯的时候，那个农村你去看看。
那树底下南墙根。
那老娘们一坐一下午。
聊聊本村的事儿都够聊的对吧？都不需要知道更多，就聊本村的事儿都能聊一下午。
是吧那点语言表达就能把他们都满足了。因为时间太多了。
我们小时候的那种电视剧，我们小时候的这个这个什么西游记呀，什么渴望呀。
那个电视剧那个那个那个当时的那个收视率。
人触达率高的恐怖。
基本上每个人都看过不止一遍。
为啥呢？当然拍的不错啊，当然拍的很好啊，但是真有那么好吗？
并不见得比现在的优秀的戏好。其实啊。
只是当时真的没有别的选择。
我给大家举个例子啊，比如说那个我小时候超级迷恋一个。
电影。
就是那个。
倚天屠龙记。
倚天屠龙记啊，我小时候特别爱看李连杰演的那个是吧？
超级好看，小时候觉得那个片儿简直无敌了。
同学们肯能肯定也有很多人看过啊，也会觉得那个片子当年真的给我们带来很多美好的回忆。
你现在回去看一看。
你现在回去把那个片子看一看，能尬死你那个剧情拉胯到不是简直令人发指，你知道吧？但是为什么呢？因为当时那个武侠片你有你有多少选择？
对吧你没有什么选择。
但是现在不一样了啊，现在这个形势确实很严峻。
艺术留给艺术的这个时间很少，留给艺术的时间很少。
这是一个现状。那我们说来这是艺术的定义。我们说它是语言表达的一种补充。
我们说那影视呢我们具体到我们的影视。
影视作品是个啥嘞？
影视作品当然也是语言表达的一个补充啊。
他表达什么嘞？
他主要表达什么呢？影视作品。
影我们说影视作品啊，它其实是一个新兴的东西啊，它比起其他的艺术形式，它其实时间要比较短，出来的比较晚，对吧？因为它是随着技术革新出来的嘛。
我们说那影视作品。
他是个什么呢？
影视作品啊。
严格来说，它其实是一个综合性的。
艺术形式。
它里面有影像吧。
有画面吧。
我们说它里面也有台词吧，有文学吧。
我说它里面还有音乐吧。
是不是啊？
而且这些东西组合在一块以后，我们还可以用剪辑的方式，剪辑艺术，对吧？蒙太奇又又再进行一遍加工。
所以他其实是一个综合性的。
艺术形式。
很难有一个。
特别具体的定义。
我们这里呢就引用。
费里尼的定义吧。
费里尼说。
影视作品啊。
其实是。
关于梦境的描绘。
我觉得这个还是比较。
贴切的。
关于梦姐的描绘。
影视作品啊其实就是一个梦。
就是一个梦。当然这个梦啊不是严格指你睡觉做的那种梦。
费里尼的观点认为啊，每个人都生活在梦境里啊。
每个人都生活在梦境里。
就是你有你的梦，你有你的梦，你们每个人活在自己的梦境里。因为你构建了你。
对你自己的认知，对世界的认知，对价值观的认知，以及对逻辑对世界运行方式的认知，都是你自己认为的。
你看到东西跟我看到的东西实际上不一样。
然后每个个体自己的梦，你看到的你自己的东西。
称之为。
真实。
称之为你个体的真实。但对于别人来说，未必是真实的对吧？就像我之前说过一般毛病的时候。
你认为你的长相跟别人看到你的你的长相可不一样啊。
对吧？
你的那个涨相就是个梦呀。
就是个梦境呀，对不对？
所以菲里尼认为啊。
每个人活在自己的梦境里面。
然后呢，那影视作品类。
共同的梦。
他就是我们大家共同的梦。
共性的梦。
所以我觉得这个定义是靠谱的。
影视作品是对。
梦的描绘。
是对大家一个共同的。
梦梦想的一个描绘。
那既然这样啊，我们来看一下影视作品，相对于其他艺术形式啊，它有什么优缺点。
知道优缺点，我们就知道。
如何？
做好我们的。
影视作品。
刚才说了。
影视作品的优点是什么？
比起其他艺术形式啊，影视作品的优点啊其实是。
全面。
就是他表达方式的全面。我们说他是他是语言表达的补充嘛，他啥都能补。
他的表达方式非常的全面。
非常的。
绚丽。
非常的引人注意，引人入胜，对吧？黑格尔说嘛影视就最主要的是引人入胜啊。
这是他的优势啊这是它的优势啊。
就是全面引人入胜。
包容性强。
对吧我们说你看有很多同学之前跟我说，他说。
我们看菊次郎的夏天主要是听歌的。
主要是听音乐的，没有音乐，这个片子就铺街了。
哎，哎，你可以这么认为。
可以这么认为，对吧？这很正常。你看这这但这不就是影视作品的优势嘛，对吧？他就靠音乐把你拿下了嘛。
所以影视它的优点。
其实是全面。
全面。
也更容易吸引人，因为他手法多，对吧？他有视觉的听觉的对吧？然后那个这个这个有音乐，有特效对吧？啊，里面也有这个好的台词，另外就是这个这个又这个这个还有好的剪辑，对吧？这些都是可以吸引你的很全面。
我说那他就没有缺点嘛。
优点跟缺点永远是并存的。
我们说。
来。
影视作品我们说它是它也是语语语言表达的补充，它其实更是文学表达的补充，对吧？那么影视出来之后。
文学受冲击了吗？
小说受冲击了吗？
短暂性的受果。
因为你刚出来的时候啊，大家总是爱跑去看电影，很时髦，对吧？但是迅速的。
迅速的。
小说又拿回了自己的。
阵地。
我们说来影视作品里面有歌。
呃，你能冲击到流行音乐吗？
我跟你说，从全球范围来看啊，顶级明星永远是歌手。
影视作品啊影视呃影视顶流永远比音乐顶流赚钱要少那么一点。
美国是这样，他们中国其实也是这样的，是吧？
只是那些歌手。
赚那么多钱，你不知道。
他们不太容易成为靶子。
什么意思啊？就是。
影视作品当然有自己的优点，但是缺点同样非常明显。
就是影视的缺点。
非常明显就是什么嘞？就是留给观众想象的空间比较少。
留给观众。
参与的。
比较少。
这个等一下我讲一下为什么这是一个缺点，而且很大的一个缺点就是留给观众的空间少，留给观众参与的东西少。
书上有个词叫心理空间，对吧？就是留给你心理。
想象的这个空间参与的这个参与创作的这个空间比较少。
好吧，那我们了解这个优缺点，我们就应该扬长避短。
扬长避短。那我们先说一下。
这个缺点为什么？
会。
称之为缺点。好吧，那我们就要了解一下。
审美的原因。
审美的原理，因为艺术啊你总要去审审美它嘛，对吧？审美到底是个什么什么机制呢？
我们为什么要去看？
艺术作品呢我们去花时间，花精力。我们说呃ten加 time。
精力和时间注意力和时间。这个注意力啊在那个美学里面。
余秋雨老师说啊，这个这个注意力是。
艺术作品的生命线呀，对吧？你甭管你是什么艺术，你首先得吸引到大家的注意嘛，吸引到大家的注意，然后让大家花时间去看。
他他才能称之为艺术嘛。
所以说我们了解一下这个。
审美。
我们为什么会去花时间去欣赏一个。
东西。
或者我们称之为艺术，欣赏一个艺术类。
为什么？
什么心态呢？
为什么会去喜欢看一个东西呢？我们说我们花时间去看小说也好，花时间去。
看电影或者追一个剧，花的时间可不老少。
在这里给大家讲审美的重要心理。
大家一定要记住啊。
审美是一个什么样的心理机制呢？
是一个寻找自我认同的。
建理机制。
就是你永远看的不是别人的美，明白吧？你看到的全是自己的美。
全是在自我认同。
审美不是在审别人，在审自己。
永远在比这个东西来找自己的影子。
这就是审美的最基本的原理。
这也跟费里尼的理论也是相通的，跟美学的理论也是相通的。就每一个个体啊其实永远活在自我的世界里。
就像我我曾经跟这这这这女女女同学说，这女孩子说，我说你不要觉得那个那个。
一个男孩子追你，他是喜欢你。
对吧他是爱你。
本质上其实不是。
本质上他是爱自己，爱你这种感觉。
他是爱自己，爱你这个过程。
他爱的还是自己，本质上是这样的。
他从你这里获得他的满足感。
明白吧？就哎就这再举个例子，我课长也曾经举过这个例子，我说我刚入行的时候。
刚赚点钱很骚包的时候，我我喜欢那个那个那个资助。
贫贫贫困地区的小孩读书，对吧？
你觉得我是爱他们吗？
我根本不认识他们呀。
能明白吧？
不就是在爱自己。
爱自己。
这个过程爱自己这个这个状态，爱自己这个行为。
爱的是自己，因为你根本不认识。
那些小朋友。
你不认识他们。
对吧而且我还说更极端的还要专门去挑什么。
那个那个那个。
藏族名字的小孩，对吧？最好还得是小女孩，对吧？
啊，这个名字还得有异域风情是吧？迪丽热巴什么什么的什么的对吧？资资助一个，为啥呢？你你你怎么可能爱的是热巴呢？
你爱的是你自己这种这个这个这个行为。
所以审美啊它就是这样一个道理。
审美从本质上是我们观众从艺术作品里面寻找的自我认同。
了解这个原理很重要。
为啥呢？
这不就在这儿吗？
参与感弱，自我他的自我认同找的少。
是影视作品先天的劣势。
做所有的事情啊都是扬长避短。我们知道我们的优势是什么，对吧？
我知道我们的优势是什么，那我们也要。
想办法去弥补我们的劣势，这样我们不就能够立于不败之地吗。所以做事情的原理啊，为什么先讲这些做事情的原理就是这样，我们要知道我们的优点是什么，发扬它缺点是什么？克服他。
对吧回避他。
吧，弥补它。
所以就是这样一个。
审美它是就是这么一个现实。
有点。
可能有点这个这个残酷，但确实就是这样。
我之前还讲过一个例子。
还讲过一个例子，我说关于这个。
审美啊。
审美就是寻找自我认同。我还讲过一个例子。
我们同学们都。
爱玩这个短视频是吧？都都都平常会看短视频。
曾经讲过一个例子。
短视频里面啊有一种视频啊，我每次刷到我都挺爱看的。
我说什么啊，就是那种。
海边的或者渔船上。
他们大鱼啊打上来一只海龟。
你没见过啊，或者在海边救了一只搁浅的海龟这种视频。然后呢。
就我的这个海龟发现这个海龟啊浑身长满了藤壶，你们知道藤壶吗？就是那个像像海蛎子一样，对吧？像藓一样长在那个海龟身上，然后这个海龟不堪重负，慢慢的就会死掉。
那么因为那些藤湖会在它身上繁殖，然后呢，这些渔渔民或者是海边的游客在救了这只海龟以后呢。
发现这是搁浅的海龟以后呢，然后就会花费时间去凿，把它身上的藤壶给它凿干净。
然后这个藤这个这个海龟呢就重新恢复了活力，因为它减轻了身体的负担。
然后嘞。
又重新游回大海。
这样的短视频往往配着煽情的音乐，很感人，对吧？因为我们大家也会觉得哇，看着那只。
海龟游进大海深处，甚至刚才好像还回头道谢了呢，对吧？甚至对吧？大家都说你看海归都知道感人还回了其下头，当然了，可能是也有可能让海龟本身是想回头啐一口，对吧？你想多了，但是配上这个文字或者配上解读，配上音乐之后啊，我大家就会很感人。有时候我看这种。
短视频特别是早上情绪比较旺盛的时候，看中短视频甚至都热泪盈。
觉得嗯真好，这个海龟。
又又恢复了，本来他有可能有生命危险啊，对吧？
他游不动了呀。
很感动。
但是我们有没有想过一个问题？
我们为了救一只海龟的生命。
干死了100多只藤壶。
这件事情到底他们善良在哪儿呢？
这件事情到底善良他们在哪？
同学们。
我们真的是。
热爱大自然的人吗？
我们真的有我们想象的那么善良吗？
并不是吧。
藤湖的命就不是命啊。
啊。
你们说为什么？
是因为。
相比于藤湖来说。
海龟长得跟我们更像。
他有头，有眼睛，有鼻子。
有辞职。
明白吧？
所以你说。
你爱海龟吗？
你爱你自己。
明白吧？
恋爱意思。
当然了，差一句啊。
这也是影视作品里面。
这个这个这个这个做共情的一种方式，就与与我们更像的那个东西，更能引起我们的共情。这个回头再具体说啊，在这里我就想告诉大家什么嘞？
审美是寻找自我认同。
你不爱任何人。
你只爱你自己。
这不是什么贬义啊，我今天讲的关于艺术是什么，影视是什什么是什么？没有贬义，全是中性词。
爱你自己没有什么不好。
对吧因为你就是你你以为你就是全世界。
对不对？世界上也有可能只有你呀。
其他任何一个你你看到的别人，看到的老师，看到你的同学。
都是你的投射而已啊。
有可能我们确实就是不存在呢。
你就是全世界，你爱你自己没有什么不好。
好吧，我讲的都是中性的话，中性的话，大家去理解这个原理，明白吧？审美。
永远是审美，永远是寻找自我认同懂了吗？好，那我们接着说啊，来，既然审美是寻找自我认同，然后呢，影视作品。
的缺点就是观众的。
他也敢弱。
那也就是啥呢？就是他找自我认同的时候啊，不是很好找。
明白了吧？
所以你看我们反过来在想这个问题，为什么影视作品混了这么多年？
看起来如此的全面，但其实他谁也干不掉呢？
对吧就是你这个。
影视作品我们说刚开始的时候为什么好？
为什么一电影曾经你随便拍啥都有人看？
因为你形势新奇啊，大家没有见过。
明白吧？
早年的时候别说看电影了，咱们中国有那种过去有那种我忘了那叫什么，在集上，反正。
像给你放幻灯片一样。
民国的时候给你放幻灯片，你都在那看。
要国外也有那老老的电影里面，我看到那种。
东西就是给你放幻灯片，你就花钱看吧。
你你就看幻灯片，都都有人愿意看早期的电影也是呀，就随便录点啥。咱们中国最早的电影就是录唱戏。
就是录畅戏。
因为这种形式大家没有见过。
没有见过。
但是这个形式这个全面的红利吃光了以后。
劣势就开始显现了。当然了，全面的这个红利还在前进啊，比如说人家研究出3D是吧？研究出各种特效，新的特效，就等于在这叫扬长，在扬长这条路上还在不断的前进。我们这节课呢就来着重研究一下怎么弊端。
怎么闭板？
就是这个参与感。我们说参与感，我们前面说了艺术的生命线就是A加T，就是观众的attention加time，对吧？
attention注意力。
我们说。
注意力。
加时间的这么一个概念。
注意力加时间这么一个概念。我们说注意力加时间在我们影视作品里面叫啥呢？
叫啥来？
叫期待。
就是引起一个。
引起观众的一个期待。
引起一个观众的期待，必须是他的期待，对吧？你讲的再花哨，他没有参与感呀。
他没有参与感呀，如何让观众参与到影视作品来呢？
最。
好的方式最常用的方式就是引起他的期待。引起他的期待以后嘞，那这个事儿就不是你的事儿了。
就是他的事儿，他要验证他的期待。
这是人的一个很贱的一个。
本能。
就他一旦有期待了，他会想验证一下。
他这个期待，这就成为了他的事儿了。
这就是让观众来参与的。
也参与了在这呃关于这个呢，我们在这个教材上也有个术语，叫追索型注意力。
追索型注意力。
就是让观众产生的一个注意力以后呢，他还想追索追索。
这种词呢。
就是专门用来装逼的。
是吧没有什么用，而且听了很拗口，什么叫什么追索型注意力。你就说吸引了他的注意力之后，然后他就在想看看后面到底咋地的。
对吧。
大白话就是这么意思，就吸引了观众的注意力。他想知道后面到底咋地了。
就叫所谓的追索型注意力。但是我再次跟大家强调一下，对于我们影视作品来说，吸引一个观众的注意力永远不是难事。
因为我们手段太多了。
明白这个道理吧？我们影视作品手段太多了。
大家如果有接触网网络大电影啊，就是那些那个那个网络电影啊。
你们应该。
了解网络电影前几分钟在干嘛？
打架。
或者黄色。
要么在打，要么在露大腿。
你去看所有的网络电影，95%以上，前几分钟要么在打打，要么在露大腿。虽然这段打或者这段色情与后面的剧情有可能毫无关系。
但是他一定要这么做，为什么呢？就是他用最简单的方法获取你的注意力。
注意力。
用最简单的方法获取你的注意力。
当然了，我不推荐这种方法，因为我们有很多种方法，影视作品是获取注意力最容易的一个艺术形式。
他理应有各种各样的方法，这个我们以后可以讲。但是我告诉你，现在的网大基本上用这个为啥呢？我们回到这里。
我们说费里尼说影视是一个梦啊。
费丽因说影视是个梦啊。
梦里啊最主流的两样东西。
就是性誉暴力。
梦里。
人的梦梦里，包括你的白日梦。
梦想里。
最主流的两个东西是信誉暴力。
所以。
性与暴力。
当然，过审层面啊。
呃，是是是我们是不提倡的。但是我们因为是上课，我们。
从学术角度，我们必须承认性誉暴力就是现代电影的。
生命线。
是基础。
因为他他是我们共同的梦呀。
明白吗？你的梦离不开性誉暴力，所以主流商业片也离不开。
也离不开。
当然审查那你不不会轻易让你通过。
你需要在审查的范围内合理的展现信誉暴力。
所有的事情都是这样，永远是在。
做这个平衡。
明白吧？你也不可能说啊，那行明白了，性与暴力呗，那我就拍个黄片，那你就。
是吧那你就要进去了，是不是？不是这么玩的啊，来回到第四部分啊，这个刚才说这个追索型注意力，我们知道一下，这是个术语。但其实听我的啊，就是注意力加时间。
就是注意力加时间。
那如何获得一个普通观众的时间呢？根据前面我们上面说的，审美永远是自我的，每一个人只爱自己。所以你我我们又知道人有一个验证期待的本能。
你凡是给他一个期待，他一定会去想验证。
这是一个本能。所以在影视作品中，我们把一个注意力转化成一个长时间的注意力，转化成一个追溯性的注意力。我们用的就是让观众产生一个他想要验证的期待。
那什么样的期待观众是愿意验证的呢？这一课概念比较多啊，干的东西比较多。我我希望你们。
事后啊记下笔记之后，是事后多多想一想啊。
什么样的期待是观众预比较愿意去验证的呢？
可预期。
就是可预期范围内的期待。
因为可预期范围内的期待。
还是他了起来。
而不是你的期待，不是你营造的期待，是他的期待。
他只爱他自己，明白吧？
可预期范围内的期待。
所以啊。
很多年轻同学，包括你们在座的几个。
我第一次问你们，我说哎，你喜喜欢什么样的故事？
想写一个什么样的故事，将来成成为呃这个职业编剧之后，想写啥样的故事？
10个人10个同学。
有8个会跟我讲。
想写一个悬疑故事。
我想写一个悬疑类的故。
悬疑类的故事是最不应该。
写的故事。
最不应该先写的故事，因为悬疑啊是你的自海。
是你的期待。
观众啥也不知道。
然后呢，你在这个过程中，在写的过过程中，拍的过程中。
特你特别的爱你自己，你你觉得你的智商比观众高，你掌控于他们与鼓掌间。
你觉得特别的爽。
但问题你忘了一件事情啊。
观众才是买单的那个人呀。
你要让他爽呀，要让他看呀。
所以悬疑片是最不讨喜的一类片子，除非你有其他方面过人的本事。比如说你的影像风格。
比如说你的演员阵容。
或者是你的讲故事的方式，你真的能够让他心甘情愿的觉得。
你真牛逼，我服了。
否则的话，不要这么做。
新人初学者。
从业前20年不要去写悬疑悬疑片。
那是。
反人性的一种做法。
秀你的智商，秀你的爽感，让你觉得你比观众强，让你觉得那你你你你确实做到了爱你自己了，对吧？那你让观众咋整呢？你是挺爱你自己呀，对吧？那观众爱谁去？
观众爱谁去。
你的想象里面肯定观众得爱你，观众会觉得哇，这个编剧智商好高啊，我服赖。
他他他没别的事干了吗？
他没别的事干了吗？
他玩会抖音不好吗？
他来看你秀智张。
所以说啊这。
题外话啊。
我们说。
观众最愿意验证的期待是哪种呢？
他可预期范围内的期待。
当然啊，我不是说让你们写到最后那个结果如他所料。
我没有这个意思。
我是让。
观众有一个可预期范围内的期待。
你最后给出的这个期待呢，跟他预期范围内的大范围是一致的。但是呢哎。
有创新。
这是最好的结果呀。
明白吧？
不是说给最后给到一个所有人都想到的结局，这就叫满足观众了。不是这个意思啊。
是让观众有一个期待范围，然后你在这个范围里面进行创新。
进行创新。
嗯，举个例子啊。
嗯，再讲一个概念啊。
在这里啊讲到观众期待啊，再给大家讲一个概念，有个概念叫。
叫期待。
期待世域玉有没有撇？
来有个概念叫期待失欲。就说你看啊我们说观众有一个可期待范围内的结果，对吧？
那我们他妈怎么知道观众期待什么？
我们怎么知道观众7白？
这个东西吧。
就叫期待食欲，就是观众人呢大概会期待的范围啊是差不多的。
是差不多的。
人的期待啊跟受教育程度。
你生长的环境，所以这个宗教信仰是有关系的。
所以就叫期待私欲。就比如说啊东方人跟西方人的期待私欲啊肯定是不太一样。
人类啊肯定有共同的期待食欲，这个是肯定的。比如说啊。
爱你的妈妈，这个相信是全人类共同的期待是语。
对吧这个就是共同的期待事。但是呢东西方会有微小的差别在某些具体的领域。
比如说我们经常遇到的啊，我们在实战中经常遇到，比如说战争片。
我跟你讲，东西方的战争片的。
期待就完全不一样。
你去看美国的战争片。
美国的战争片全主题都是反战。
庇护室都是回家。
你们回去看一看。
看一看那些美国的战争片，它的主题都是反战，逼故时是回家。
中国的战争片呢。
如果出现这种主题，就要挨骂了，就要扑街了。
中国的战争片主题是保驾卫国。
保家卫国。
对吧美国的战争片里面的主角是我打的这场仗，我再也不想打了，对吧？我想回家，我想过平安的日子。中国的战争片是敌人如果来我还打。
吧大到最后一颗子弹。
一滴血盖死他对吧？这是我们。
东方的战争战争线的。
期待好吧，这就是我们说期待世欲啊是跟人的这个这个这个文化背景啊有一微小的区别的。你要了解这个概念啊，了解这个概念啊，不能说你看啊这个这个这个我就不说哪部片子了，反正是有一部著名的战争片，咱们中国的。
他来套用。
美国这套。
这个这个这个。
概念。
营造了。
一个。
反战的主题。
就导致。
误判了。
咱们中国观众的期待食欲，而且那个战争边还还很重要，因为它是。
相当于很献礼的一献礼的一个片子啊。
这个这个这个就搞错这个事儿，大家要了解一下这个情这个东西啊，期待诗欲是不太一样的。东西方啊或者是每每一种文化或者随着年代都不太一样，明白吧？随着年代的变化都不太一样。
这个人的这个期待。
这个虽然年代都都不太一样。我那天在。
那天在。
对对对对对对。
开车的时候听听听到一首老老歌。
我小时候听的时候，我觉得这首歌挺好听的呀，没有任何问题，对吧？台湾女女女歌手刘若英唱的。
直接说吧，反正留人现在也不太差了。
刘刘若英唱的歌，我小时候觉得挺好听。现在听我听里面的歌词，我觉得我天哪这虎狼之词啊。
放在现在，如果是现在某个歌手唱这种歌，简直会被。
会被女网友骂死。
会觉得你怎么这么贱。
我们女人就应该这么贱吗？
就是就是完全反语权，你们明白这个意思吧？
你看这就是年代的差异，对吧？我们说有地域的差异，有年代的差异，这很正常啊，大家要了解一下来，我们回来说。
我们一个影视作品要营造一个观众预期范围内的期待。
预期范围内的期待能够解决我们。
一定程度缺乏参与感的。
需要参与员。
我们说事情都是留两面的对吧？影视这个艺术它的优点全面。
有冲击力。
花里胡哨的啥玩意儿都有。
对吧给你造的让你没看你让你看什么没见过的东西，让你爽感十足。但是呢缺点就是。
参与感。
脚啊，你才敢。
参与感弱，嗯也也也也也不行啊，都你说了算了，是吧？这个这个互动呀，我们说首先所有的艺术都是交互的，因为它本身就是语言表达的一个一个补充嘛，语言表达为了为了啥？为了沟通啊。
你我我你你我我就我去看那电影，俩人挣到光你说我我啥也没干，光你说。
对吧那样肯定不行。
所以说这就是。
弥补这个。
弥补参与感。我们说所有的东西啊实际上都是这样啊都是这样。
从。
从这个这个这个发挥他的优势，弥补他的劣势。
本身就是一个平衡。
来，我们说。
我们就从这一点入手。
如何？
让观众。
产生一个。
可预期的。
期待。
产生一个他想要去验证的期待啊，这里插一句啊，我们之前讲过那个呃故事的结构的时候，我们说故事有三幕式嘛，其实。
故事的三三部分也是从观众的角度来讲，其实就是我们叫吸引。
日期。
和满足。
这不就是整个我们说从观众的角度，从观众审美的角度的一个心理过程吗？他首先被你吸引了，然后产生了预期，然后最后得到了满足。我们说我什么为什么会满足呢？是因为在他可预期的范围内有跟他想的不那么一样，不完全一样，好吧，那我们今天着重。
要给大家解决的是预期问题，预期问题就什么样的预期？
能够带来追索型的注意力，持续的注意力，对吧？带来A乘以T呢。
然后他现在成立type呢。
我们从。
现实生活中。
就可以学到一些就可以学到一些。这个我线下课的时候给大家讲过，我今天再讲一下。
啥呢？我们说我们早上去遛弯。
我们早上去遛弯。
咱们门口啊有条通汇河，对吧？早上去遛弯。
我每天早上出去遛弯的时候啊，我就会发现。
哪里聚集着一群人？
哪里就产生了追索型注意力？
至少有这么几种模型。
第一种。
通会河边。
有老头钓鱼。
有一个老头在钓鱼。
拎着个桶拿着个杆儿，对吧？坐在那钓鱼。
旁边永远围着几个小青年或者是老头儿，以男性为主。
在那看。
在那看他钓鱼。
这群人的。
注意所行注意力。
被这个老头儿。
拿下。
成功拿下，对吧？
这是一种。
还有。
早上遛弯，接着往前走。
还有一种模型。
老头儿下棋。
两个老头在这下棋。
然后旁边也围着一群人看。
也围着一群人看。
获得了大家的。
A和T。
第三种模型常见模型啊。
有个老头掉坑里了。
对吧随便什么坑，马路上有个坑或者下水道。
或者河里，老头掉进去了。
肯定一群人围着看。
咱别说老头了。
掉进去一只猫。
都为一群人看，你们去短视频上看看。
什么小猫小狗掉进坑里，那种短视频玩播率相当高，你也不认识的。哎，我跟你说，都搞不好，都不是咱中国的狗。
你不知道哪儿的狗，谁家的狗，对吧？它掉坑里了。
你也看半天。
我们先就看这三种模型。
他们分别是什么模型？他们是有什么样的魔力？
引起了大家的追索型注意力。我们说钓鱼钓鱼是个啥模型？
钓鱼是个欲望保险。
这个老头有个明确的欲望，他有个行动目标，这个行动目标虽然很简单，但是很明确。
在这种情况下。
就有人愿意付出。
追溯型要注意力去follow这件事情。
你看是不是很神奇，对吧？有些同学说啊有些同学说，哎操那些人就是闲的，一看就是一帮不务正业的人在那看我们这种正经人。
才不看。
同学们，我也自认为是一个正经人。
我也其实我也没有在那围观过老头钓鱼。
但是我告诉大家。
包括我。
包括自认为正经人的你们。
每一个人。
从那个老头身边经过的话。
你都会低头看一眼他的头。
你怎么就那么忍不住呢？
你怎么这么没出息呢？
低头看了一眼他的头，虽然只花了一秒钟，但是你这一秒钟被这个陌生的老头给拿下了呀。
你以前有多少个疫秒啊？
我们说张一鸣拿走你不少一秒，人家就是。
对吧。
字节跳动，马上就中国首富，对吧？马云拿走你很多个一秒。
人家也是那么首富，对吧？马化腾拿走你很多个疫秒。
人家也是对吧？
也是也也也也首富，曾经也首富。
这老头怎么还拿走你一秒呢？
既然你的每一秒都这么值钱，为什么还被这个老头拿走一秒？
对吧你不要清高。
任何人的疫秒他都能拿走。
因为他有一个明确的。
有一个明确的。
目标。
那为什么明确的目标能拿走你的时间呢？
这不就是我们说的吗？可验证范围内的期待呀。
可预期范围内的期待呀。
这个老头钓鱼这件事情，你为什么看见那桶？
你想知道他掉没钓到。
你想知道他钓了个啥鱼，多大？
这不就是你的预期，你的验证吗？你根本不关心那个老头，你不爱他。
你不爱他。
你只爱自己。
你只关心我猜的到底对不对。
你不关心那个老头。
那老头回家中午回家炖鱼也没叫你去呀。
是吧你不关心他，关心的是你自己。因为你有一个可预期范围内的期待。
这就叫。
忘他。
我们说来下棋也有很多人看，对不对？
下棋也总是为一群人啊。
为什么？
同理套用这个可预期范围内的期待，可验证的期待。
因为下棋的模型更简单呀，这叫博弈呀。
是不是啊？
这叫哎弈咋写？这叫博弈啊。
博弈必有输有赢啊。
所以这个模型也是一个非常容易验证的一个期待呀。
博弈对吧？
而且我们说看下棋的那帮人真的关心。
谁输谁赢吗？
真的关心这俩老头A赢还是B赢吗？A赢和B赢对他们来说。
没有区别，对观众来说。
我们关心的是什么？我们关心的是我你看我说应该这么走吧。
哎，你看我说你看这一步走的好，对吧？你看他就赢了，我们验证的还是自己的期待，爱的还是自己。
我们说坑。
对吧。
看到有人掉坑里了。
那我们验究什么呢。
验证的是脱困。
脱困是也是一种非常古老而传统的故事模型。
也是我们非常愿意验证的。
我们看他怎么脱困，为啥？因为我们说啊。
影视啊。
故事啊，它永远是个梦。
陷入困境是也是我们梦里面经常会出现的情况。同学们啊，我们梦里面也经常陷入困境啊，让人追，让人堵上了，让人揍了，对吧？
高考高中考试答不完卷了，忘拿笔了是吧？这些梦经常出现这些事经常出现在你们梦里吧。
为啥呀？因为你们先天就害怕遇到困境啊。
影视作品不就是梦的放大吗？
拨款。
当然了。
与脱困相反的，如果那个老头很爽，如果那个老头正在爽，你也会看。
就你看到一个老头倒霉，你会看。如果看到那老头正在爽。
你也会看。
他在低处你会看它的坑里你会看它在高处你会看。
正在数航，比如说。
老头中彩票了。
一个老头中彩票了。
一定会获得我们所有人的。
A和T我们的最作性注意力。
同学们。
如果你听说一个人中彩票了。
你马上会发出好几个。
这个这个这个这个连续的问题中了多少？
交完税还剩多少？
他怎么画？
我们都很想知道，对吧？我们告诉他啊，他买了个车，买什么车？
是吧。
为啥？
为啥你这么关心啊？
他买那个车，他他开的时候，他也不会让你坐的。
为啥？
梦呀。
你没有这个梦吗？
你不也有这个梦吗？
对吧。
所以说你看与坑相反的那老头如果爽了，他掉坑里了，你也看他上去了，你也看。
这是上去了一年看，你看啊这个不就是。
很多影视故事的基本类型嘛。
我们说一个明确的w，这叫什么？
如果以望头为支点做的话，那这就不就是金羊毛吗？
对不对？那不就是金羊毛吗？
我们说来博弈类型。
这个对手如果很强，跟你足够强，你也很强，两强相遇。
这不就是超级英雄吗？
对吧。
这不就是超级英雄嘛？当然了这个对手如果。
如果是你的一个目标。
那也可以是这样嘛。
对吧。
我们说来掉坑里很可能就是个鬼屋嘛。
你出不来就死在那儿了嘛。
对不对？
我们说老头如果很爽，很爽，有多种形式啊？假设是中彩票，那不就是如愿以偿吗？
对吧。
我们说来。
这些事情啊都能获得我们的追溯型注意力。
但是这个追索型注意力啊。
很短暂呀。
就像我刚才说的，我说那个那个那个我们看那个老头桶里有没有鱼，就看了一秒钟啊。
对吧我们就看了一秒钟，一秒钟那个撑不起一个电影啊。
对吧一秒钟太短，我要长一点。
那咋去？
不如说从这个模型你有这个模型了，你可以放大呀。
假设我从那边旁边走，一个老头在钓鱼，我看了一眼他的头。
然后往前走，就花了一秒钟时间给他。
这时候我听到旁边有人窃窃私语。
说这老头儿老里头不简单。
他是他年轻的时候是亚洲钓鱼大赛冠军。
是吧曾经破过亚洲纪录，一分钟在那个什么。
什么湖上吊起过什么100多斤的。
草鱼是吧？你一听我操亚洲钓鱼冠军。
我操，那我得看看是不是啊亚洲钓鱼冠军，你这辈子遇到过另外一个吗？我一个也没有遇到过，对吧？你肯定想看看。
肯定想看一会儿。
你有可能就多花一分钟给他。
反正一看哎时间也没有那么着急，上班也没有迟到看一分钟吧。你看从一秒钟就变成了一分钟。我们只不过给这个老头加了一个简简单单的人设。
加了一个简简单单的人设。
然后你看了一分钟，觉得。
手法是挺熟练的对吧？但其实不还是钓鱼嘛？又刚要走。
然后旁边人说，我操，你别看老头一分钟没掉上来。
你知道为什么吗？
老时现在眼睛瞎了。
年轻的时候是钓鱼冠节啊。
现在他已经瞎了。
因为瞎了才退役的嘛。
所以今天他在忙掉。
我说你本来要走，你是盲跳。
我这辈子还没见过有人能忙掉啊，他完全靠手法捏那个线，就知道上钩了没有吗？
就不用看片儿。
我操，那我得看看。
是吧而且看他它到底真没真，是不是真瞎了。
又多看好几分钟。
是不是？那为什么又多看了呢？
因为我们在人设中又增加了一个缺陷。
增加了一个缺陷。
我们说来你看他钓鱼本质上其实看他的看的是他的这个w，看的是他的这个行动目标，对吧？因为这个行动目标让你产生了想要验证的一个。
呃，期待想要研究。
那我们这个目标可不可以放大？
对吧。
目标可不可以放大？
比如说。
他。
钓这个鱼。
是。
这个这个这个。
家里有个孙女儿。
生病了对吧？没有钱治病，也没有钱给他买东西吃。刚做完手术，现在呢就想钓条洗钓条鲫鱼，给孙女熬汤喝。
把这个目标放大。
对吧？
甚至哎你如果没有没有直观的想想象的话，那个老头手里还有你孙女的照片，那一看哎这小女孩挺可怜的对吧？
我说你看又凭空又多看几分钟。
我们说还可以，这就是目标方大，还可以引用对手，对吧？
来了个小伙子。
他是退役的钓鱼冠军，小伙子是正当年的钓鱼冠军。
做它上游。
也开始钓鱼。
而且。
装备比他先进，对吧？鱼饵比它多，在俩打窝，把鱼都吸引过去。
又引入一个对手，对吧？再引入一个时间所。
几点钟钓不到是吧？老头说到中午要是钓不到，我就跳河死掉。
啊，或者旁边有人个拿枪逼着他们。
对吧谁钓不到就干掉谁。
谁先掉到就干掉另外一个掉的慢的，这不就是鬼屋吗？
是吧。
就各种各样的方法能够让你不断的花时间。
看这个老头钓鱼。
他就慢慢的变成了一个电影了。
变成了一个。
有故事能够持续吸引大家看的电影。
所以这节课就是给家大家讲一下。
从艺术的本源的角度，我们再去思考一下，我们为什么要写一个故事，以及一个故事真正的核心的东西是什么？
很多时候啊我们拿到一个故事。
你觉得挺好。
但是人家看完之后呢，觉得没有吸引力，对吧？或者是用一些大白话说，有些有些人会觉得哎你这个故事没有钩子啊。
对吧没有东西勾着，我一直看呀。
然后你也不服。
对吧你觉得我写的挺好的呀，你咋觉得不好看呢？我跟你说，人家觉得不好看就是不好看。
因为一个故事不是说哎，我符合了某种类型，我也写了这个这个这个各种元素，为什么还不好看呢？
就是你没有一个。
让观众付出追索型注意力的能力，没有牵着观众走的能力。
这才是影视。
故事最本质的东西。所以我说我这节课应该早点讲的，就是这个意思。你们要了解你写故事的本心本源初心是什么，是牵着观众看完。
这才是最重要的。
那什么东西牵着他看完呢？
你要了解。
观众并不爱你。
你不要痴心妄想，让观众爱你，仰视你，佩服你，因为佩服你把它看完了啊，不会的，他爱的是他自己。
明白吧？就像我们的课，我们的课也很长，几十个小时看完的人没有那么多，为什么呢？是因为学习是一个逆水行舟的事儿，他得不到满足。
得不到满足。
明白吧？
所以看完的人很少，那是什么少数那看完的那些同学，那几万个同学为什么能看完我们的课程呢？
他是因为爱我吗？
no,同学们，他满脑子都想的是等我学会了以后，等我出名了以后，对吧？等我他妈有钱了，你看着我。
对吧等我学会了，我要出名，我要有钱是吧？
爱的还是他自己。
所有坚持看完我们课程的那些同学，坚持一直在看的那些同学。
每天晚上都拿这个瓶在那，谢谢大家，谢谢大家，我能得到这个最佳编剧，都在那获奖感言他都想好了。
爱的是他自己。
同学们。
所以。
我们用这几个模型告诉大家。
牵引。
牵引住。
观众的注意力。
是有方法的。
我们之前的课上反复讲的那些类型也好，结构也好，招也好，都是在辅助你做这件事情。
你现在再通过这样一个理念，再回过去看以前你学的那些知识，你写的那些东西。
你会有不一样的感觉。
好吧。
再讲最后一个知识点。
为什么我说我早上出去遛弯的时候，这些东西很能吸引我们注意力呢？
这些东西还有其他一个共性的特点。
就是这些东西是真实的。
就是他是我早上。
真真切切肉眼看到。
这又是影视作品吸引大家注意力的另外一个。
法门。
另外一个关键点，你们要注意就是真实。
就是真实营造真实感。
要让你的事这个事情看起来像真的发生过一样，观众才愿意投入情感，投入共情。
投入注意力，好吧。
这节课讲的就是这些内容。我们从艺术的原理的角度开始讲，让大家理解影视作品到底是什么，让大家看下去。我们为什么要看这个东西，对不对？如果我们连这个事情都搞不清楚，那就不要不要写了。
你你你你都不想看都不愿意看，不愿意花时间看电影。
那就那就那就别玩了。
下课吧。
嗯。